hey welcome to the monitor I'm Peter
Ruben it wired and let's get into it
with an album this week we usually kind
of slip this in the middle or put at the
end let's start it off and that album is
anything in return by Toro y Moi you
probably don't know him by his birth
name Chaz Bundick or if not his birth
name than what has become his birth name
or something and anyway Toro y Moi the
name that will be affiliated forever
alongside the term chillwave do you hate
that word so do i I think so does Toro y
Moi because he has proclaimed that he is
kind of moving away from the languorous
electro-pop that torley muah and washed
out and neon indian and all these other
groups have kind of peddled in for the
last couple of years so he's kind of
moving in more of a disco e direction he
had the side project that he was doing
that with though between you and me and
whoever else is watching it's pretty
chill wavy and this is not a complaint I
might hate the word but I like to sound
and what's nice about this is for me
with a very difficult time listening to
lyrically dense music when I'm working I
enjoyed your way for this very reason
sure there are lyrics but they get you
know it's all part of the experience and
this is all keep going with this the new
album from touring law that is out this
week anything in return I suggest you
give that a listen let's talk about
comics ok so I'm going to give you a
thumbnail description and I don't even
think I came up with this but it
certainly has gotten into my head like I
came up with it so I'm just going to
take credit for it and tell you that
this is a comic book that is like The Da
Vinci Code if it starred velma from
scooby-doo and also a superhero and the
comic book in question is called the
answer i did not mean for that to come
out that way comic books in question is
the answer it starts this week on dark
horse comics and it is drawn by mike
norton and actually the idea came from
mike norm but it has been being written
by dennis hopeless who just started
doing cable and x-force for Marvel in
the past month or two now what's
interesting about this for me is I
happen to love four-issue miniseries
because it's kind of an in and out and
nobody gets hurt scenario it's not
asking you to to kind of buy-in for
months and years at a time you know it's
going to be a foreman thing you know
it's going to cost you 12 to 16 bucks
depending on the book and the house and
what you're going to get out of it is a
nice tidy contained Ark the answer
number one which is out this week as I
mentioned on dark horse kind of brings
together the Velma character in question
is actually a librarian who loves
puzzles which is near and dear to my
heart because I love puzzles and my
mother was a librarian enough about me
there is a superhero involved whose name
is let's see if you can come with the
answer the answer is the answer super is
named the answer at any rate their paths
cross there are nefarious bad guys
involved there may or may not be a cult
involved it is off to a rollicking start
and it is definitely going on my weekly
or my monthly rather to-do list I don't
keep a Pulis because I read it all
digitally but you know what I'm saying
at any rate the answer starts this week
for the next four months on dark horse
let's talk about TV TV show I want to
talk about this week actually started
last week and I shamefully did not know
about it until we had already taped the
monitor but I also want to blame the
network the show in question is real
husbands of Hollywood on b.e.t which may
sound familiar to you because starting
in twenty eleven comedian Kevin Hart
produced these as small interstitial
segments for the b.e.t Awards it was a
parody whose lampooning the whole Real
Housewives of Atlanta New Jersey
wherever cities they are I don't watch
them but I am aware of them but this is
fantastic and it is now a show on b.e.t
Kevin Hart took the idea spun it out
into a whole mockumentary series and it
is hilarious it stars Kevin Hart and
Boris Kodjoe and Duane Martin and Nelly
yeah seriously and Robin Thicke and Nick
Cannon that is kind of the core group of
guys who are all married to women who
are more powerful and famous than they
are except Kevin Hart is not actually
married I don't think but Kevin Hart
star has been rising in recent years not
only his stand-up but he's had a
recurring role on modern family and he
and one of the best guest appearances on
the ill-fated party down that I've ever
seen as a business-minded rapper but
Kevin art is hilarious and his deadpan
is like no other the show is
freewheeling and a little bit of
improvisational but it is hilarious
Kevin Hart is he deserves as much as
he's getting and more if you don't think
this sounds like a show you would find
funny I defy you because you are wrong
and you should watch it it is on Tuesday
nights this is the second week it's on
they run here reruns all the time real
husbands of Hollywood seriously take it
from me sleeper hit huh oh this is bad
quality that's not a breakaway suit is
it yes it is I'm trying to find a
printer in Super ever gonna get on why
tell me why Wow but that is it for the
monitor this week we will be back next
week with more pop culture but until
then inspirational catchphrase here